hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm amanda and this is the samuel and
amanda show where we talk about money
marriage and life so in this video we're
going to be talking about discipline and
how to have little hacks and tricks
about how to have discipline and
willpower to get what you want in life
and one of the things that you have done
really well and i'm super proud of you
is what
i'm losing weight i've lost nearly a
stone now i'm like nearly nearly there
now so incredible like you are basically
you look
exactly the same as you looked when we
very first met
and now you've had three kids yeah three
kids together and um you know super
super impressive stuff so so we can talk
about discipline in terms of weight now
i always say if you want to get a
six-pack you want to get ripped don't
speak to me i'm not the guy
you want to become financially free you
want to make a million pounds in
property i'm your guy however if you
want to get in shape maybe amanda is
your girl wow i mean that's a big
stretch but i can certainly give my tips
on what i've been doing to do it because
i have done it through zero exercise
which i think is quite cool because
marvin would hate you saying that i know
and it's like no offense to marvin's
loving's great and i am gonna start
working out at some point because i
really want to turn but i think i just
really wanted to master discipline and
discipline myself in my food habits so i
think that's the big thing because
people always say
um it's more what you eat than
exercising so you can exercise but
there's no use exercising if you're just
gonna be eating crap anyway yeah so i'm
not gonna give an opinion on it because
i don't feel qualified too but
discipline in terms of health
also discipline in terms of finances
which is really important we can talk a
little bit about money management had to
be disciplined with money and also just
discipline just in terms of life and
getting what you want so i thought we'd
start maybe i could read a few quotes
about discipline and we could talk about
whether we agree with them or
you know how it might help but also you
have to keep watching this video till
the end because shortly i'm going to
show you an incredible
live illustration life hack which has
revolutionized amanda's health
that'll be really extreme but no you
really do stick around so all right
firstly first quote that we have around
discipline is um and you've got quotes
as well but this one is self-discipline
is when your conscience tells you to do
something and you don't
talk back
oh interesting so you're basically not
arguing yourself you're just going with
what your
what your conscience is telling you to
do
motivation gets you going but discipline
keeps you growing
i love that because it's true motivation
like comes and goes sometimes you can
feel really motivated to lose weight and
then you can wake up the following day
and be like oh i'm actually not that
bothered but discipline is then what
keeps you going through it so i agree
with that if we don't discipline
ourselves the world will do it for us
interesting i agree with that to a point
if you're not hard on yourself and i say
this a lot of our training programs some
of our training programs are like make
people do live calls to estate agents
and they're like oh my gosh i'm not sure
and or if they do something i'll call
them out and it's hard and people find
it a little bit intense in the room
sometimes but i'll say look if we don't
do it in here
it's gonna happen out there and i'd much
rather you
get um have a bad experience or have you
know an agent put the phone down on you
when you're in a safe environment and we
can just laugh it off and go right next
then it happen when you're at home on
your own and you're gonna feel really so
yeah if you don't put yourself if you
don't put yourself through it then
someone else will put you through it
that's very interesting i agree with
that also applies to children as well
like if you're not going to discipline
them at home and like you know then when
they go out into the big bad world it's
true okay
without self-discipline success is
impossible period
that's what you mean by self-discipline
doesn't it yeah here's the thing right
here's the thing i'm gonna stop reading
quotes now because this is my stance
this is my take on it okay i think that
discipline and self motivation and come
on and you've got to stick to what
you're saying
if you don't love what you're doing
then you ain't going to do it i
some people go oh my gosh samuel you're
so hard working but i am
but it's because i love what i'm doing
in some areas i'm really lazy when it
comes to
um doing housework
i'm not hard working at all
would you testify yes i testify because
i don't like doing it
so i think what you want to do is you
want to create a business where you
actually love doing the bits that you
want to do and then you just delegate
and outsource the rest
people would disagree with that but
no i think you're right well pete does
the quote isn't it love if you love what
you do you never work a day in your life
no but listen right
in self motivation trying to
it just doesn't work
because
how many people get try and get
self-motivated it just it doesn't last
yeah exactly it doesn't last so my
thought process is if let's say you want
to be a property millionaire and you
know to be a property millionaire you
need to pick up the phone and you need
to call investors and landlords and
and agents but you don't like doing it
if you don't like doing it
you can do you can try and motivate
yourself and get up in the morning i'm
gonna do it anyway i'm gonna do it
anyway and push yourself through it but
then your life is miserable
or you can say you know what i'm gonna
put myself in an environment where
everyone's doing it and it's normal
and my friends are doing it and who you
hang around with is who you become now
that's a good quote that is that's a
good question and it's very very true
and i think as well in terms of like you
know you've done super super and i'm not
saying my opinion is correct i'd love to
know what you think maybe let me know in
the comments but in terms of
um
in terms of being successful i think
that health wise and i'm i consider
myself reasonably healthy i'm not i'm
not like i've got sticks back or
anything not super slim but i can lose a
few pounds but i consider myself
reasonable health healthy and i think
you know what in terms of being healthy
again it's environment because when i'm
around like marvin my personal trainer
and i'm around if if i notice when i put
white on so does my brother so does
ricky so does toast the environment yeah
what do you reckon yeah yeah no i think
environment's like really important
because if you're around people that are
just eating burgers every day and you're
like big then you don't notice that oh
all of us are big but i think as well
sometimes you can if you've got a
certain goal but then you're hanging
around people that are not of the same
mindset as you yeah then it can kind of
drag you down or they can be the
naysayers like oh no don't do that oh
that's not possible you're not smart
enough you're not smart enough
disconnect yeah you have to disconnect
from those kind of people so for example
i don't hang around the same people that
used to hang around with in high school
for example because sometimes you can
just find that actually our paths are
different we're not going the same way
so in that way then you can just like
okay i won't spend that much time with
you because then you'll find that when
you spend time with people that are of
the same mindset uplift you then you can
go further and one of the reasons you
often go away on training courses you
travel acro across the world
yeah
not just to learn but it's also to be
around yeah it's great being around
like-minded people and even at your
events yeah you know like when we go to
the advanced training i love that
environment like when you go to the
four-day ones especially it's like at
the end of it you kind of like oh no
it's over because everyone's like on the
same level same vibe it's just such good
energy so i love that another thing
that's gonna keep you healthy and keep
you happy which is really really really
important uh health-wise is
to
drink lots of water
honestly drink this is this is i don't
want to show you a hack with this in a
minute drinking water is an important
part of health laughing a lot laughter
is the best medicine and hanging around
good people oh my goodness like
i think it is healthier
to
eat chocolate with friends
than vegetables alone
i mean to a point
being around good people laughing a lot
and drinking a lot of this
that's what's going to keep your energy
up and here's a really interesting thing
okay manny didn't agree with my last
comment
[Laughter]
i mean i think it's all about balance i
mean you can't just nothing to do with
balance and everything to do with
friends laughter and water
so i told amanda when we first got
married you didn't drink much water i
said you need to drink two liters a day
she's like oh man oh two liters i'm like
it's just three pints okay three pints
or
three pints or six
small glasses okay
so she starts drinking six glasses okay
a day she doesn't like that pint it's
like too big so she's drinking six
little cups a day
however
this is weird now
she says samuel it's overwhelming me she
says i'm drinking
six cups a day
but it's just over i can't do it anymore
and i'm like well i'm drinking
three pints a day and then we realized
something
okay you do you you hold this you got
yes you owed this because then you'll
get waiting on me okay pint
cup
no
no
oh
the pint is the same as the cup
and i was drinking six of these
i was drowning my organs were drowning
crying out for help
and then we realized that the cup is the
sat holds the same as the pine
i mean
there's so many lessons in there what's
the lesson what's the lesson in there
well you can trick your mind so
for me
it's like i i thought that the pint was
too much like i can't do that i'll have
six of the little ones
but actually
well another way that i trick i i think
you can shoot your mind is
a lot of my students they're phoning
estate agents to get deals
and they're like oh man i spoke to five
people and all of them said no oh
right and they get kicked taken out
again so what i say to them is i say
look instead of instead of being like oh
man this person
to reach the agents say the script
but just time how long you're on the
phone
and every week when i see you i want to
know how many minutes you've been
talking to estate agents
because
if you've had five no there's chances
are you rank an agent and they put the
phone on you quite quick and you're only
on the phone a minute so you've had five
notes it sounds really bad oh five of
stages rejected me it sounds really bad
but if you say um this whole past week i
was on the phone for five minutes
he's like well so it's again it's it's a
trick um and there's so many different
things like this it's almost like an
optical illusion an optical illusion to
success so
you know drink lots of water yeah be
happy because if the mind is happy i
think the body is happier um get around
good people environment what is your
closing the best success tip the best
tip around discipline that you could
possibly end this podcast with and the
pressure is on oh my goodness it's a
quote by abraham lincoln let me just get
it so i tell you exactly what he's
saying abraham lincoln very very good it
says discipline is choosing between what
you want now and what you want most
so for example i'll just use simple
example of food when i'm out when i go
out for a meal i think i look at the
menu and i think oh i'd love that mac
and cheese
but then it's like that's what i'd want
in the moment but is it going to get me
to my goal that's why i always have to
ask myself is it am i eating towards
where i want to get to and if the answer
is no then it's like i'll have to skip
that unless it's a tree like whatever no
it's almost like if you do now what most
people won't yeah then you'll be able to
live how most people don't yeah exactly
i don't think i need to make it up i
just i'm just filled with this thousand
of knowledge
hey guys if you've got questions for me
in amanda what should they do you should
comment them down below right now
comment them down below don't forget to
hit the like button subscribe and we
will see you next time thanks for
watching guys bye
[Music]